[Music]
one of the biggest surprises of the
errata of the Internet is we thought
when the internet came out it would be
provide everyone new fundamental tools
to learn about the world around them and
it would actually remove the censorship
and information that we get before the
Internet we used to get our news from
three TV stations and they were it was
carefully edited and carefully described
and after the internet came out we you
can you can search new sources from
around the world great the problem is
the internet also became a source of its
misinformation there's that very famous
cartoon that says you know on the
internet no one knows if you're a dog
with a dog typing in a typewriter you
don't know the source of your
information which is the beauty of it it
was the reason it was actually created
by particle physicists working at
thermal at the Large Hadron Collider or
at least CERN the laboratory where that
now is because thousands of physicists
needed to communicate with information
without caring about where the source
came from but that the fact that the
source is is shielded is of course of
great concern
nowadays in the political world among
other things and so we have to think
about ways that we can address that now
of course information providers can try
and work on that too but we basically
all have our own responsibility to
become our own filters we have and
that's why it seems to me the
educational system has to provide those
tools those filtering tools and that's
one of the reason why I think science is
so important because it's built in
filtering tools it recognizes that we
all want to believe and the end as
Richard Feynman said the person you have
to question most is yourself knowing
that you want to believe when you when
you read something that validates your
beliefs you should be skeptical of it
and your beliefs and you should look out
for other sources so we have to train
people that one source on the Internet
is not good enough you have to search
broadly to see if it's validated
moreover you have to empirically test
those ideas if claims are made you can
look out and look at the data to see if
those claims are validated we all have
this new responsibility because we have
a sudden wealth of information to become
our own filters and I can't see any way
that we can move into a an Internet
guided world where the democracy remains
vibrant if the public doesn't have the
tools to distinguish sense your nonsense
and and for me that's one of the reasons
why I talk about science because I think
it provides us one of the key tools to
do that one thing seems very clear to me
education should not be left to private
enterprise any more than police or fire
or military or in my opinion health
because their fundamental rights of
people and in a society that has the
financial resources to provide
individuals a safe and secure
environment which is really what
government is all about part of that is
to educate young people it's a right for
every young person in a society to in a
modern advanced industrial society to
receive an education and that means not
that we have the option of private
education but we have to ensure that
students are provided opportunities to
become the most productive adults they
can be in a modern complex society that
by the way doesn't mean treating science
and other things as purely information
that's a mistake
we used to feel that schools where
places that imparted information well I
can get more information in my in my
cell phone now than I could in any
school but I can also get more in
misinformation what we need to recognize
is that science is not just a bunch of
facts but it's a process for deriving
facts and it's a process to tell sense
from nonsense what we need to provide
students nowadays is a filter that they
can use to assess all the information
and misinformation they're barraged with
so they can become responsible citizens
and that filter involves teaching kids
how to question questioning is more
important than answering it seems to me
when it comes to school we should teach
kids how to question and say let's see
how we could get the answer let's
skeptically ask questions let's test our
ideas let's search through many sources
now this should be the basis of any any
child's education today and that
public or private but the government of
course has to ensure that students are
have at least equal opportunity students
are going to achieve differently but at
least have equal opportunity access to
education and that means we have to be
able to account for possible private
education systems some of which are
frankly designed to keep students from
thinking to keep students believing some
myth that may have existed a long time
ago for fear that understanding how the
universe really works might undermine
their faith well doing that is child
abuse because we're withholding
literally resources that will help
children become more effective adults
and so there's an a very important role
in government to ensure that all kids
have equal opportunity access to the
process by which we gain information and
then as they go out in the outside world
they'll get lots of information I
received a PhD but I will say even in
physics most of what I know now I
learned after I got my PhD
[Music]